This is for people who care about the work that I
do. I want to tell you about the Newsroom, which
is just a fancy title for our Patreon, where you
get a lot of fun things and you can simultaneously
support what we're doing around here. What is it
that we're doing around here? Oh, you know, just
low key, trying to change how journalism is done.
I left Vox in 2019 to start doing journalism on my
own, and now we are at 3 million subscribers. I
used “we” because it's no longer just me. It is
now a big team of very talented people who make
all of this happen. To do really good journalism,
more and more, we need to rely on support from the
community. So that's where the newsroom comes in.
You help support independent journalism, and
the good thing is you get something in return.
Every month we do a behind the scenes vlog where
you get to meet the people behind the scenes,
see our processes, see a lot of shenanigans. It's
a really good time. But you also get to weigh in
on the thumbnails and the titles that we choose.
Even story ideas, you get access to my scripts,
the full, uncut interviews that I do with
experts. And every month you get a music
track from our composer, Tom Fox, that you can
use in your own videos. So go check out the
newsroom. If it's not your thing, that's fine
if it is your thing. I'll see you over there.